familie kunze aus dem berchtesgadener
land gibt uns einblicke tanja kunz und
ihr zehnjähriger sohn florian wohnen in
freilassing in bayern die 55-jährige ist
yoga lehrerin sängerin und
schauspielerin florian geht aufs
gymnasium in salzburg weil die schulen
wegen des lockouts geschlossen sind kann
der sohnemann seine freundin nicht sehen
und spielen stattdessen auf der konsole
die auftragslage für tanja ist alles
andere als einfach wegen des block down
starb sie können die yoga kurse abhalten
auch gesangsauftritte fallen ins wasser
ich habe im prinzip seit sieben monaten
fast keine aufträge mehr eine yoga kurse
wurden großenteils gecancelt ist
natürlich sehr schade und sehr traurig
und es macht mich auch ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen wütend weil ich finde dass
die leute sich einfach nicht an diese
regeln gehalten haben und nun muss das
ganze berchtesgadener land ausbaden
ja und wie geht s familie kunst heute an
tag zwei des lockdown wollen wir sie
jetzt persönlich fragen wie zugeschaltet
ist anja kunze guten morgen ihr tag 2 da
gibt es hoffentlich noch kraftreserven
wie wird dieser tag heute für sie
aussehen
hallo guten morgen naja wir sitzen jetzt
da und machen hausaufgaben besuchen den
stoff der nächsten tage nachts zu
arbeiten oder mitzuarbeiten ganz ehrlich
die schulen sind noch mich besonders gut
auf hybrid unterricht eingestellt
in dem fall ist es jetzt die salzburger
schule die dafür zuständig wäre aber ja
wir werden uns da jetzt wieder so durch
wurst und das haben wir ja in den
letzten monaten geübt oder und meiner
schlechten auftragslage als
schauspielerin sängerin und yogalehrerin
habe ich natürlich jetzt auch die zeit
aber gut ist das nicht und natürlich bin
ich enttäuscht darüber
vor allem weil ich jetzt auch in den
sozialen medien ständig lese und sehe
dass die leute wütend auf die politik
sind ich glaube dass die politiker im
großen und ganzen einen guten job machen
und dass die menschen dafür
verantwortlich sind bzw verantwortlich
ist natürlich das virus
wo liegen denn jetzt ihre größten
herausforderungen in ihrem alltag
na ja schon mit so einem jungen menschen
hier zum beispiel englisch zu machen und
ich glaube es ist nicht nur bei uns das
problem dass kinder sich von ihren
eltern nicht ganz so gerne unterrichten
lassen und dann auch schnell mal ein
bisschen wütend oder orts fällig werden
wenn ich was erkläre was du nicht
verstehst oder was ich akzeptiert aber
wir haben übung und wir werden sie jetzt
bestmöglich versuchen und wir haben
natürlich auch da muss ich sagen da bin
ich sehr dankbar für im gegensatz zu
vielen familien das glück dass wir in
einem haus wurden wir haben genügend
platz mein mann arbeitet oben möchte
jetzt nicht gezeigt werden weil er voll
mit arbeit ist aber wir haben genügend
platz dass wir hier alle unseren
arbeitsbereich haben und dann gott sei
dank auch im garten wo wir uns dann mal
austoben können wenn die situation hätte
es wird ja dann schicke ich meinen sohn
abstrampelt wir haben zum wirken großen
garten können draußen rum gehen in
unseren daten raus können dir halt nicht
nur geschickt die gründe als wir haben
wir sie es endet seit fürchte ich möchte
auch noch sagen was ich glaube dass ich
ich glaube dass hier es gibt im in
salzburg einen privat sind
ich sagte ihnen jetzt nicht aber das
kann ja jeder rauskriegen wer wird hier
sehr viel gesehen und in diesem sender
mit meiner meinung nach ganz bewusst
gegen die politik der regierungen sowohl
in österreich als auch deutschland
geschossen und es werden dort
vermeintliche wissenschaftler oder schon
wissenschaftlich denn die zur bord
gebracht
melden sich zurück und die propagieren
seit monaten dass das alles falsch ist
dass das alles fake ist und das halte
ich für brandgefährlich
ich denke dass sich ein offizieller
seite da endlich jemand dagegen werden
müsste mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren